[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment
of harry potter theory in today's video
we're going to be discussing
sirius black harry potter and the family
trees of the wizarding world more
specifically
we're going to be discussing the
possibility that harry potter and sirius
black
are actually blood related now we know
that sirius was a good friend of harry's
father james
and that sirius was appointed as harry's
godfather because of james and sirius's
close bond
harry was immediately embraced by sirius
as long as harry was alive
sirius would always look out for him and
watch over him
however on the night the potters were
murdered sirius was tragically framed
for the crimes of peter pettigrew
this was especially tragic because in
harry's time of need
the first opportunity for him to truly
act in his godfather role
sirius was unable to be there for him
later in life when harry discovers that
sirius black is
a his godfather and b not a convicted
murderer the pair reestablish their
friendship
and sirius almost assumes a kind of
fatherly role
harry idolizes sirius and i think a lot
of that comes from sirius's close
connection with his father
who harry never got to know furthermore
sirius is intent on making up for lost
time
by going all in on his godfather role
but what if
interestingly sirius was more than just
harry's godfather
what if sirius black and harry potter
were actually blood related
well as it turns out there's a fairly
convincing fan theory for this one
one which i'm going to first explain and
then criticize
in the wizarding world bloodlines are
usually quite clear and that's because a
societal distinction is made
and recognized between muggleborns half
bloods and purebloods
harry potter was part of a pureblood
family the potters
a fairly wealthy bloodline that invented
all sorts of potions
contributing to the family fortune to
say that harry was privileged
is an understatement but that shouldn't
take away from the fact that he had an
awful upbringing
as it so happens serious black also came
from pure blood lineage
the black family is one of the largest
oldest and wealthiest wizarding families
in britain and it has been expressed
that many other wizarding families are
distantly related to the blacks
in the books films the black family
tapestries etched onto the wall of the
drawing room at number 12 grimmell place
where it depicts the beginnings of the
family in the middle ages
all the way up to the depths of its last
members the family who go about the
family motto
du jour meaning always pure
is mostly comprised of pureblood
fanatics who believe that pure bloods
are simply better
and certainly more worthy of magic
alright so how does harry fit into this
well as it turns out at one point on the
black family tree
there appears to be a familiar last name
a potter
on the black family tree it is revealed
that at one point in history
a certain doria black married a charles
potter given that this occurred many
years ago before harry and sirius
it could suggest that harry and sirius
are in fact
related there isn't too much information
on charles or doria out there
but we do know a few things charles was
the uncle by marriage of cygnus
alfred and walberger black which would
make him the great uncle of sirius black
the third
the serious black we know and regulus
black the second
chalice's heritage is also incidentally
linked with draco malfoy
his great great uncle charles and doria
had one son who is not named
and is not known to have had any
children before the names of harry's
grandparents were released by rowling
many speculated that charles and doria
were actually his grandparents
just quite far removed however the
potter family lineage has since been
more or less
clarified in conclusion because they
were on opposite ends of the family tree
harry and sirius did not share any blood
however given that wizarding families
have been intermixing for centuries
there is a possibility that they are
linked just further back
did you guys know this did you ever
think about it let me know in the
comment section
below if you enjoy the content please
like the video and subscribe to the
channel until next time
it does not do to dwell on dreams forget
to live
you